[Music]
[Applause]
yeah here's how the survey works we ask
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was to punish me my dad
would make me now ben stiller out stand
in a corner Mindy Kaling wrote do extra
chores Jaden Smith wrote co-star strip
and strip yeah very strict family uh
when Miss Utah said we need to see how
to create education better I thought kat
dennings wrote she sounds kind of dumb
Ava Mendez wrote she must have been
nervous Sarah Palin wrote I agree her
totally with yes too
[Applause]
my favorite secret getaway is Alec
Baldwin wrote the Greek islands Jessica
Biel wrote Costa Rica Edward Snowden
wrote
nice try Conan when I watched Paula
Deen's latest apology I thought Larry
David wrote she has rough days ahead
heidi klum wrote I hope she's learned
from her mistakes Paula Dean wrote crap
I forgot to thank my Jew lawyers I'm
writing my own lawyer thank you
my favorite Ben and Jerry's flavor is
Jeff Goldblum wrote Chubby Hubby Aubrey
Plaza wrote chunky-monkey
Donald Trump wrote Trump e Trumpy it's
fudge ripple with chunks of wig wig yeah
we're enjoy they're good wig that's good
wig you farted my favorite thing to do
in the summer is Bradley Cooper wrote
spend all day at my lake house Kristen
Wiig wrote go on a crazy vacation with
friends Lindsay you Olin wrote drive my
car into pedestrians with the top down
yeah you get the air and the Sun my
greatest claim to fame is Mark Wahlberg
wrote I have an Oscar nomination Will
Arnett wrote I have two beautiful
children
Vladimir Putin wrote I have more Super
Bowl rings than Dan Marino oh wait we
have Vladimir Putin fans here or Dan
Marino fans oh they're Putin Oh Putin if
there's one there all shirtless in
speedos yeah Hey
[Applause]
one day that wig is gonna fly right off
when you do that when I do that people
there's convinced we have a wig if Jesus
came back today I would Seth Rogen wrote
be very surprised Megan Mullally wrote
have lots of questions for him
Wilford Brimley wrote chased him off my
lawn with a hose Messiah doesn't care
the most unflattering nickname I call my
spouse is Cheryl Hines fro Old Baldy
Morgan Spurlock wrote chubby cheeks
Michael Douglas wrote death valley
now that joke I endorse yeah thumbs up
on that yeah I wouldn't do that okay
before I serve pancakes I like to Giada
De Laurentiis wrote warm the maple syrup
Gordon Ramsay wrote put a slice of
orange on them Polly she wrote whip the
butter
unless she doesn't have any fancy ideas
about escape
[Applause]
god I know what will bring us together
yeah this last joke joke I mean real
surgery yeah yeah I knew the lat oh here
we go
I was the last kid I knew to lose Tom
Hanks wrote my baby teeth Gwyneth
Paltrow wrote my virginity Larry King
wrote my gills
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]